hallo herzlich willkommen meine tochter
heute gibt es von mir ein ganz schnelles
ganz leichtes ihm ganz länder das rezept
ich weiß nicht wie die cremes kennt ich
kaufe gerne und ich habe gerne
frischkäse krems auch in der paprika
creme im feinkostladen gekauft meistens
gibt die beim griechen beim türken und
diese cremes sind ziemlich teure kosten
100 raum so zwischen 24 euro und wenn er
es schon mal gesehen hat wahnsinnig viel
essig kraft seiner kleinen haken
ich habe irgendwann angefangen die krebs
einfach selber herzustellen weil ich so
weiß ich bin viel günstiger dran ich
weiß was drin ist und ich weiß auch was
nicht drin ist und was sie jetzt wissen
wollte wie man die creme macht bleibt
jetzt dran ihr braucht jetzt nehme ich
nur ganz ganz wenige zutaten dafür an
zutaten auf den frischkäse leicht egal
welchen frischkäse ihr benutzt geht auch
nur lese ich nehme als 200 gramm
ihr braucht später käse ich nehme da
meistens den vom lidl der häfler und das
ist schon eine ziemlich große packung
da gibt es glaube ich auch kleine
packungen die viereckigen ihr könnt
markierten käse neben feta-käse egal was
ihr gerade da hat davon nehme ich jetzt
ein halbes grad ist in etwa 125 gramm
ihr braucht eine rote paprika ich werde
wahrscheinlich nur die hälfte benutzen
angeboten benötig rosmarie im sommer auf
dem frischen oder den immer frischen da
habt etwas cayennepfeffer oder chili
flotten etwas pfeffer aus der mühle und
ein paar knobloch ziemlich leid meine
krähen jetzt heute im thermomix zu
bereiten weil das für mich so viel
schneller geht
ihr könnt natürlich auch andere
nächster benutzen allerdings klappt mit
einem stabmixer nicht so gute
ausprobiert bevor ich den thermomix
hatte da bleibt die paprika immer in den
zahnrädchen drinstecken
dann müsste die paprika eventuell vorher
kleider schreiben und könnten auch
probieren
ich werde jetzt hier kurz vorbereiten
und zwar schneide ich den käse einfach
in kleine stückchen dann stehe ich ein
paar knoblauchzehen legt die da ganz mit
dazu ich nehme jetzt mal so eine kleine
und große diese zwei keine also da könnt
ihr euch viel knoblauch benutzen
schmeckt dann umso besser da nehme ich
jetzt noch die hälfte der paprika
paprikas müsst ihr übrigens immer vor
dem schneiden waschen damit ihr danach
nicht mehr waschen ist da war steht
nämlich dann nur die vitamine aus dieser
dünnen haut raus
das weiße schön entfernen und dann
gerade grobe stücke schneiden sie je
nach paprika größen im team halbe oder
eine ich werde jetzt mal nur die hälfte
nehmen dann kennt ist alles hier rein
also feta-käse knoblauch und paprika und
da ist der frischkäse
man gebe ich dann noch ein bisschen
rosmarin rang
im park oder chili und pfeffer aus der
mühle hoffe ich zugeben weil er die
frage liegt und ziemlich salzig und
heißt jetzt bei stufe sechs bis sieben
ein paar sekunden nixon lassen
die piste ab und zu ein bisschen rührend
jetzt ausgeht und das seht ihr auch das
dann noch ein paar größere stücke drin
sind katzen alles nicht weil in der
mitte zusammen
steinbach diesmal
und dann nochmal stunde 67 etwa fünf
sekunden
so sieht es dann raus ich habe ihm ein
paar stückchen drin
ihr könnt entweder dann noch mal
durchführen lassen dass er richtig
homogene masse hat aber ich finde
eigentlich so mit dem stück ich in
kanada zu schlecht dann hat man ein
bisschen was zu kommen und mit nur eine
creme dann müsst ihr an der stelle
nochmal abschmecken ob wir vielleicht
noch mehr verbrauchen können
oder etwas rosmarin oder andere kräuter
richterin ein kleines glas stäbchen ab
und eigentlich dann gleich wie es
aussieht und diese creme schmeckt nicht
nur besonders gut aufs brot oder aus
brötchen
ihr könnt es zum beispiel auch zu
fleischgerichten und servieren
drillisch silber ganz lecker oder
einfach die paste sich auf ein steak
schmieren oder auf kartoffeln auf gemüse
also da oder mit frischen planen brot
schmeckt besonders gut da gibts
eigentlich viele möglichkeiten die
finden 1 sätzen
hier können sie auch eine sauce mit rein
geben es gibt doch noch mal ein extra
geschmack ich habe jetzt auch eine
ziemlich große menge rausgekriegt sind
locker 2 300 rahmen hintergrund könnte
je nach geschmack eurofighter und den
klub noch einsetzen oder weglassen
je nachdem wie ihr so rieten luftig mag
sie so jemand ans gern das war's auch
schon die creme ist fertig und ihr könnt
die gekühlten paar tage lagern
ich wünsche euch auf jeden fall viel
spaß zum nachmachen und in der nächsten
videos werde ich meine werkzeuge
vorstellen und die frage antwort videos
machen ihr könnt auch gerne fragen
sammeln ihr habt ihr schon fleißig
fragen gepostet
ich werde auch ein paar grundlagen
machen basics orten oder auch zur
einzigen gerichten und wählte auch wenn
ihr möchtet noch ein paar thermomix
features machen
da hab ich auch schon ein paar wünsche
des sehen dass ich den thermomix öfter
einsetzen soll
ja das sind so die sachen die nicht
bekommen sparer oder nachmachen wünsche
euch ein schönes
das war's